Hello and welcome to this video on project setup.
In this we're going to be going through all the different steps that are required in order
to make your first project.
Now before we can actually make a project, we are going to have to download the launcher
and before even downloading the launcher, we are going to have to create an epic login.
In order to do this, all we need to do is visit store.epicgames.com and that should direct
you to your local server for that, in this case it shows the US.
Now after you're doing this, it's going to guide you through setting up your own epic
games login.
You can use a Google, Facebook, Apple store login and that's fine, we can attach your
account to them.
But this account is going to be quite important.
It's going to be used across multiple different stores and we recommend that you create a
secure password and keep it all safe.
So once you have summed in, you're going to see in the top right hand corner there is
a blue button on the site that says download.
Clicking on this will take you to the download page and it's going to walk you through three
steps if you want to get hold of the engine.
Now the first one is to download the launcher.
That's all I'd like you to do at this point if you haven't already done it.
And once you have downloaded the launcher, it will guide you through a short wizard to
install the launcher and you'll be able to fire that up on your system.
Once you've downloaded and installed the launcher, you're going to end up in a page that looks
something like this.
Now by default, it's going to show you some epic game news.
Now this is targeted a lot more to the game's consumers.
So you're going to find that our first step in any of this is about people who are looking
to purchase games.
Now you'll see down the left hand side, we have three tabs, the store tab, a library
tab and an Unreal Engine tab.
If I was to click on the store tab, this will jump us into the game store.
It's going to allow us to purchase different games from different companies, not all necessarily
made on Unreal Engine and a number of them that are free giveaways to entice people to
the website.
Now below this, we will have the library tab.
It'll skip over that, but that's going to be the games or software that you have purchased
from the store.
It's this last tab which is of interest to us here called Unreal Engine.
If I click on that, it's going to bring us up a very different page.
It will give us a number of other tabs that we have across the top here.
Now all of this is specific to creators or people who use the engine.
So the news that we see in this instance is going to be a lot more about people who are
making computer games or animations and much more specific to that, rather than the external
games player.
We will also have a whole load of different tabs that are going to offer us starting points.
The last two tabs, Reality Scan, is dedicated to our Reality Scan software for photogrammetry.
I'm not going to cover in this.
And Toyin Motion that we touched on a little bit in the last video.
It's a paired down version of Unreal Engine.
It's a lot more easy to get up and running with.
Now the one that of interest to us that we're going to jump to is Library.
This is going to give us a number of different sections.
At the top here, we have the different installed engine versions.
I have 5.5, 5.3 and 5.6 installed at the moment.
We'll probably start with none and just a button prompting you to a download version.
Below that, you'll have all of the project files that can be found on the engine.
And below that further, we have something that's called the FAB Library.
We will touch on that as we go on.
Now the first thing you're going to need is a engine version downloaded.
If I come up here, you can see that there is a plus button that as I push,
it will bring up another version to install.
This will give us a dropdown with all the different versions of the engine we will be
capable of installing.
And an install button.
Next to the install button, we have another dropdown.
And that's going to allow us to set it to current or go away and remove.
If I was to tick install, it's going to ask us a couple of different things.
First thing it's going to do is ask us where we want this installed.
What folder and path that the engine itself will be installed.
Now this is not the project files themselves.
The projects will be independent of this and can get quite big in themselves.
Now there is the ability to browse.
Below that we have options.
Now I think it's worth looking at the options quickly because this is going to give you
an idea of how large the engine is.
Down here we have a download size.
This is just what would be downloaded is 14.54 gigabytes.
However, the required storage space once it's all installed and compressed is twice that
at 38.3 gigabytes.
Now the core components that are required are 33.5 gigabytes themselves.
So these are required.
Without them you're not going to be able to remove them.
But there are a few other options.
For content I would always leave this on because this is a number of textures and effects
and stuff which you can easily add to a project and use.
I find it very useful but it is optional.
The templates and feature packs are 3.7 gig.
I would always leave that on as well.
And I'll probably keep an engine source.
There are also other options for debugging.
If you're working in C++ you may find this useful.
We also have a number of different options here with target platforms.
And I have them all turned off by default.
You can see that these can get quite large.
So a point 8 gig for Android Linux is coming in here at 20 gig.
So you might want to turn these off if you know you're not going to be building to any
of these.
All the compilation is being done elsewhere.
Once you hit apply you can install the engine and it will go away and it will install the
appropriate engine and you'll have a version that is brought here.
Now that might take you half an hour or so depending on your speed of your internet.
So do feel free to pause the video there and hit off again if you have not previously
done it.
Now next up let's create a project.
So I am going to hit the launch button here.
And that's it.
This is going to go away and fire up Unreal Engine and allow us to select our starting
project.
Now after you've gone away for a bit it should bring you to a screen that looks like something
like this.
Now we're going to ignore the recent projects and we're going to have a look down at what
templates are available to us.
The templates are broken down here by industry as I've made here.
However, don't feel like you are restricted to these.
We've always changed things as we go ahead.
First off we have games.
Now on the games you can see we have the option for a blank template.
We also have a first person, third person, top down, handheld, AR, virtual reality and
vehicles.
These have functionality put together in them that allow you a good starting point.
What's also interesting to see is if you look down in the settings we have first person
as a main here but within variants we have a few more.
We have none, an arena shooter, a survival horror or all.
What this is going to do is add in some extra functionality, some extra classes and models
which will allow you to easily make one of these games.
If you select none you're just going to get a very basic first person shooter with a gun
and your character.
Any of these are going to add in extra functionality and all is going to add everything into it.
You're not limited to these, you can add these in as a later date if you need them.
The main thing that's really useful is for example in the third person characters we
have a couple of variants but this is going to provide us with animations and skeletal
mesh for money and Quinn which are our two default humanoid characters we can use within
the engine.
Now top down again is going to give us a strategic or twin stick setup.
So these are your main, sort of a quick look at the templates that are also available to
us.
We have one that is set up and geared for virtual production or VR scouting and we have
one set up just for lighting rigs for performance and end display.
This is what is often used for virtual production where we will display stuff, project stuff
on tools.
Within architecture we have a design configurator, a VR or desktop collaborative and a handheld
augmented reality setup.
Within automotive and product design and manufacturing again this is going to give us things like
the product configurator which in this example we have a guitar but it could be used for
pretty much anything and it's an application in itself where you just need to add in the
different settings and plug in what you need.
Finally simulation for this we have our virtual reality setup and our black simulation document.
So let's select for this we are going to go into games.
We are going to select the basic third person setup.
We're not going to worry about the variants in this.
We're just going to go with the basic.
For this we have a project location and a name.
So I'm going to set this to just some defaults.
And let's have a look at the different options that we have on the defaults.
We have blueprints or C++.
Now blueprints is our visual scripting language which we are going to be using in this example.
C++ is going to download all of the C++ code which if you are used to working with C++
is very useful.
You can always convert a blueprint only project to a C++.
You cannot go back in the other direction after.
The target platform we are looking at is desktop.
Here we are going to use desktop in this example and the quality presets we are going to set
to maximum.
Okay, after we've done this I'm going to hit the button to allow us to create this project.
Well, once you've done that you should have something that looks a little bit like this.
Let's talk a little bit about how an Unreal project is set up.
Now in most software applications you would usually find that your project is saved to
a singular file.
So for example a Photoshop would be saved to a .psd file, Word to a .doc and Maya to
a .mb.
Unreal projects don't work like this.
Firstly because the Unreal projects themselves can be incredibly big.
Secondly, because you will often be working with something like source control and there
will be numerous people working on the same projects.
Therefore it is beneficial for us to be able to have all of the different files saved out
to their own unique files.
This allows us for source control to be able to lock files when one person is editing them
so other people can't edit them at the same time.
It also allows our projects to be moved around, move around parts of a project or parts of
an asset and not have to copy the entire project.
So whenever we create a file within Unreal it will create a file on your disk.
Though for example a level would be saved as a .umap file, a asset would be saved as
a .umap asset.
Things like a material would also be solved as a .umap asset.
If you would import a model from Maya for example that too would be converted to a .umap asset
and if you imported an image from Photoshop that too would be converted to a .umap asset.
So this means that a project itself is going to have lots and lots of different files to
be parts of it and they will be converted to a specific type of file which is readable
and understandable by Unreal Engine.
Now you will be able to see all of these files on the disk.
However it is highly recommended that you never move the files around manually outside
of Unreal Engine and that is because the files all have references where the references connect
to each other and if you move files around outside of the engine in Windows Explorer
for example you're going to break all of those references and your project is going
to stop working basically.
You can usually fix them within the project but there's a lot of work.
However if you move things around within the editor it will automatically update all of
the corresponding references.
So that brings us to the end of the project suss up.
In the next video we are going to be looking at the interface and how to navigate it.
Thank you very much.